♪ ♪ ♪
- Le système de santé
en Norvgegege, ça fonctionne
très bien.
- Julien Bourrelle vit en
Mais il habite dans cette jolie
ieieieue d'Oslo depuis peu.
Il a donc dû changer de médecin
de famil
- Sur In
centraliser, et puis, le
servicesesesest très bon.
On va sur ce qui s'appelle
"Santéèèèège", donc, le site
du gouvernement norvégien.
aussi vécu ailleurs dans le
monde.
- On clique sur "changer de
médecin", puis ça nousititititis
les médecins dans notre région
où on peut choisir.
- Il se dit impressionné
par la souplesse du systè- Doncs
sur 1250 qui sont disponibles.
- La grande transparenn n n n nn
accepté par les médecins
norvégiens.
- Tout le monde peut voir quels
méde e e e e existent, combien
de places ils ont, combien ils
peuvent mettre même sur une
qui n'a pas de place.
Ça veququququque l'accès, pas
seulement médecins, mais aussi
au registre est très bon.
- Le système actuel a été mis en
place en 2001.
La Norvège vivait alors une
crise ececececececececececececet
accepter les patients de leur
choix, il n'y avait aucune liste
Près de 10 % de la population
n'avait pas de médecin attitré,
la plupart étant des personnes
plus malades ou
donc choisi de renverser les
rujujujujujujourd'hui, c'est le
patient qui choisit.
- Tous les habitants de norvège
ont droit à un médecin.
Ils peuvent aussi changer et on
téléphonez chez votre
généraliste,  ils doivent
prendre le téléphone en moins de
deux minutes, ils doivent même
donner un rendez-vous
de cinq jours.
- Petit détail : les p
doivent payer des frais
modérateurs de base à toutes
- Pour une visite chez un
médecin, c'estrrrrrrrès 20
euros. Des fois, un peu plus,
des fois, un peu moins.
200 euros par an.
- Ça serait peut-être
l'équivalent de 5 CaCaCaCaCaCaCt
code de trois à cinq fois plus
fonctionne bien, les gens,
normalement, voit
quelque chose de positif de
payer une petite partie du coût
d'utiliser un médecin.auauauaua.
- Autre particularité
norvégienne : les patients
peuvent évaluer la performance
de leur méorororororororortail
public.
- Un peu comme quand on va au
restaurant,  quand o
Google Maps, on met des étoiles
pour différents services.
- Il est noté?
- Il est noté.
- Julien Bourrelle était venu en
Norvège pour obtenir un doctorat
en ingénierie.
Au fil du temps, elle a plutôt
choisi d'étudier à fond
la culture norvégienne.
dededededededededevenu un confér
très prisé sur le sujet.
- Maintenant, je vis de ça.
Je fais des conférences partout
en Scandinavie, et maint
aussi à travers le monde sur
les différences culturelles.
- Il observe que les médecins
n'ont pas de statut social
paeueueueueueueueueurs salaires
sont très bon, l'équivalent de
deux fois et demie le revenu
moyen au pays. Mais c'est
beaucoup moins qu'au Québec, par
exemple, où les médecins ont un
revenu cinq fois supérieur au
salaire moyen.
- Mais même le concept d'élite
existe très peu en Norvège.
- Ce médecin généraliste,
sous ministre de la santé,
expliquer les salles d'urgence
étaient souvent bondées avant
la réforme. C'est beaucoup moins
le cas aujourd'hui. Mais la
Norvège comme d'autres pays fait
face à de nouveaux défis en
médecine générale : populati
vieillissante, augmentation de
la charge de travail, pénurie
de médecins.
- On lit tout le temps d
histoires que les médecins
généralistes, ils travaillent
jusqu'à quatre, cinq heures,
après, ils vont aller au jardin
d'enfants pour
leur enfant, ils font à manger,
et les couches, et ils
continuent de travailler
de 10 heures jusqu'à minuit
chaque jour.
- Il y en a un ici.
- Le taux de satisfaction
générale envers le système de
santé demeure très élevé en
Norvège. comme le confirme
la conjointe de Julien Bourelle,
norvégienne d'origine et
ex infirmière en milieu
hospitalier.
Le modèle norvégien est-il
exportable au Canada? Peut-être,
mais il faudrait aussi importer
une partie de la mentalité
locale.
- Ce qui est typiquement en
Norvège, c'est qu'on veut avoir
une contribution au pays pour
aider la société, plus que pour
av
plus élevé.
- L'exemple de la Norvège
démontre que les patients qui
s'ensuivit sur une longue
m m m m m m m m m m m m m méden
moins besoin d'être hospitalisés
et leur qualité de vie s'en
trouve nettement améliorée.